翻訳: Makiko Miyashita
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
今朝 起きてからもうすでにコーヒーを
飲んだ方いらっしゃいますか？
手を挙げてください
沢山いますね
今日ちょうどブレイクタイムで
コーヒーも出てましたからね
それではあの
コーヒーが苦手だとか
コーヒーが飲めないという方
どうぞ遠慮なく 手を挙げてみてください
チラチラといますよね
実は僕も コーヒーが飲めないんです（笑）
ホテルや喫茶店で
人と待ち合わせをしたり
レストランで食事をした後に
僕はいつも コーヒー以外のものを頼みます
なぜかというと不味いコーヒーが
飲めないからなんです
生まれて初めて飲んだコーヒーが
とても残念なことに 不味いコーヒーで
それがトラウマとなってしまい
自分はコーヒーが嫌いだと思ってる人が
沢山いると思います
未成熟な豆を焙煎すると
えぐみや雑味 渋みの原因となります
そして 抽出して時間がたったコーヒーや
再加熱したコーヒーは
酸化して酸っぱくなってしまうんです
この酸っぱさをコーヒーの酸味と
勘違いしている人や
雑味やえぐみが 本来のコーヒーの味だと
誤解されている方が
残念ながら沢山いるんです
僕は静岡の
コーヒー焙煎卸業の長男として生まれました
物心ついた頃から
身の回りにコーヒーがあり
世界各国から届いた
コーヒー豆が積まれている倉庫が
僕の遊び場でした
そんなわけで
小学生のころから 中南米に行って
コーヒーの勉強 栽培の勉強をしたいと
思うようになったんです
1975年 今から42年前 僕が18歳の時に
念願がかなって
中米のエルサルバドルに留学しました
エルサルバドルは
中米で一番小さな国ですが 1975年に
世界で３番目のコーヒー生産国になりました
これは僕が勉強した国立コーヒー研究所が
世界でもトップレベルの研究所で
そこの研究の成果が
この数字を現したと思います
こんな素晴らしい研究所で
勉強できたことは
僕にとって本当に幸せなことでした
静岡を出るときに
両親と約束したことがあります
それは 勉強が終わったら
おとなしく静岡に帰ってきて
家業を継ぐことだったんです
しかし エルサルバドルとコーヒー栽培に
すっかり魅了されてしまった僕は
勉強が終わったら産地で生きると
親に宣言し 勘当されてしまいました
宣言したのもつかの間
政府軍と
反政府ゲリラによる
内戦が勃発してしまいまして
毎日 銃声と爆弾の鳴り響く中
生活をしていました
多くの友だちが犠牲になりましたし
僕自身もテロに巻き込まれて
機関銃で撃たれました
しかし 幸い九死に一生を得て
今 こうして皆さんの前で
お話をしているわけです
友を失い
美しかったサルバドルが破壊されていく
そのうちに首都サンサルバドルにも
戦火が及ぶようになりました
しかし 僕にはもう日本に
帰る場所がありませんから
ロサンゼルスに疎開しました
しかし 食べていかなければいけません
そこで メキシコ料理店に
職を得て そこで働くようになりました
毎日毎日
いつか絶対に
コーヒーに戻れる日が来ると
自分に言い聞かせながら
タコスを焼いていました
そんなある日
日本の大手コーヒーメーカーの創業者が
僕をスカウトしにロサンゼルスまで
やってきたのです
静岡のコーヒー屋の息子が
栽培の勉強をして
親に逆らって勘当された挙句
ロサンゼルスでプラプラしているらしい
ということが耳に入ったんですね
非常に魅力的なオファーをいただきました
しかし 僕はエルサルバドルに
帰りたかったので お断りしたんです
ところが サルバドルの政情は一向に安定せず
またその創業者の熱意にほだされて
日本に帰り入社し
そして赴任したのが
カリブ海の島ジャマイカでした
そこでブルーマウンテンコーヒーの
農園開発に着手したのです
これは僕の人生にとって
とても大きな出来事でした
その後
ハワイ島
スマトラ島
マダガスカル島
レユニオン島で
コーヒー農園を作ったり
品種の研究をするような仕事をしていました
日本には時々帰っていたんですが
日本に帰るたびに
日本のコーヒーが
どんどん不味くなっていく気がしました
レストランに行くと
美味しい料理とマリアージュしたワイン
そして 必ず最後にとんでもない
不味いコーヒーが出てくるわけです
皆さんも多分 経験されたことが
あるんじゃないかと思います
レストランは
食材やワインをこんなに厳選するのに
どうして こんなに不味いコーヒーを
平気で出してしまうのか
本当に テーブルを叩きたくなるような
心境でした
コーヒーはこんなもんじゃない
こんなコーヒーをそのまま放っておけば
日本のコーヒー文化はダメになってしまうと
痛感しました
しかしこれは お店の責任ではないのです
こんなコーヒーを販売させている
コーヒー業界に 一番問題があったわけです
これは1975年から現在までの
国際相場を示した表です
赤い線が その年の
最高値
青い折れ線グラフがその年の最安値です
世界最大のコーヒー生産国
ブラジルで天候異変で不作になると
コーヒー相場に直撃します
例えば1975年
20世紀最悪の霜がブラジルに降りました
コーヒーの木が枯れてしまったんです
そうなると 当然価格が上がります
そして 他の生産国で増産が始まるわけです
78年まで価格が上がり続けました
コーヒーは植えてから
３年で収穫ができます
ですから78年に世界中でコーヒーが
採れ過ぎてしまって
大暴落したわけです
コーヒー業界は 懲りもせず
毎回毎回こういうことを繰り返してきた
これが産地の現状なんです
ところが
1995年
このころからまたコーヒーの価格が
上がり始めました
このときには
ブラジルは普通に生産されています
何も起きていません
何が起きたかというと
投資家の 投資の対象になったわけです
まったく
関係ない
天候には関係ない高値が生まれました
投資家による
マネーゲームの対象になってしまったわけです
そして 97年に
投資家たちは売りぬいて 富を得て
しかし この時 2001年に
世界中でコーヒーが大変余ってしまいました
その結果
2001年から2003年
ちょうどこの黄色のところですけど
『コーヒーの危機』とよばれる
とんでもない状況が起きました
生産コストの半分以下でしか
コーヒーが売れないような
その２年間
本当に産地は悲惨な状況でした
生産者が
夜逃げ同然でいなくなり
農園は銀行管理になり
朽ち果てていきました
これを僕は 目の当たりにして見てきたのです
そして 2003年を過ぎると
今度はコーヒーが足りなくなり
価格が上がり始めました
コーヒーの価格が上がると何が起きるか
生産者の裏切りです
契約がありながら
高い値段でよそに売ってしまう
国際価格が上がったからと言って
日本のコーヒーショップや
ホテルやレストランは
卸価格を上げるなんてことは
絶対に許してくれないわけです
そうなると
当てにしていたコーヒーが入らなくなった
コーヒー会社は
よそから高いコーヒーを買って
損してでも売らなければならなくなります
僕はそのどちらが良いとか悪いとか
言ってるんじゃないんです
生産国も消費国も
この国際相場に振り回されているのが
現実なんです
そこで僕は考えました
品質に対する対価を払えば
生産者は安心して
コーヒーを作り続けることが出来ますし
また 我々は安定したコーヒーを
供給することができます
しかし
そのためにはコーヒーの価値を
上げなければなりません
なぜならば
品質に見合った価格で
売れる市場を作らなければ
生産者から買い続けることが
出来ないからなんです
そのためには 明確な品質基準が必要です
世の中には
様々なコーヒー製品が売られていますよね
そしてまた その全てが
最高級品と言っているわけです
皆さん
例えば缶コーヒーもそうだと思いませんか？
またインスタントコーヒーもそうですよね？
スーパーマーケットで安売りされている
レギュラーコーヒーでさえ
「高級豆使用」とか
「厳選された逸品」などという言葉が
散りばめられてるわけです
ワインや牛肉は 明確な等級があります
しかし コーヒーには
目安となる等級が無いのです
そこで 品質基準を作ることを考えました
皆さんコーヒーがワインと同じように
素晴らしいフルーツだ
ということをご存知ですか?
フルーツだからこそ
農園の中でも畑によって
微妙な環境が違います
風の影響も違います
雨の降り方も違います
そして 日の当たり方も違います
品種によっても出来る物が違います
さらに言えば この写真のような
完熟豆になったコーヒーは品質が良いわけです
つまり 農園の中で
品質のピラミッドができていきます
ひいてはこれが
産地ごとのピラミッドにもなっていくわけです
コーヒーは焙煎と抽出も重要な作業です
ただし 味の８割を決めるのは
この生豆の品質なんです
その生豆の品質をどうやって
維持したまま日本まで輸送するのか
輸送方法ですね
そして 生豆の保管方法
さらには焙煎したコーヒーのパッケージまで
そこまでを含めた
品質基準を作らなければならないと思いました
そして この品質基準の中でも
ベストオブベスト 最高のコーヒーを作り
すそ野を広げていくという
ビジネスプランを作ったんです
これを以前働いていた
大手のコーヒーメーカーで
経営会議の時にプレゼンをしました
あえなく却下されました
誰にも この言っていることが
解ってもらえなかったのです
そして
もうこれは自分でやるしかないと決心し
会社を辞めて
新しいコーヒーの文化を提案する
会社を起業しました
起業してすぐに 世界の産地を訪問し
生産者から
僕の眼鏡にかなった
コーヒーを直接 商社を通さずに
輸入することを始めました
最初に手がけたのは
このピラミッドの頂点のコーヒーです
底辺から始めても
なかなか解ってもらえませんからね
そして出来たのが
『Grand Cru Café』
シャンパーニュのボトルにコーヒーを詰めて
200グラム １本１万円で販売しました
焙煎した後に豆から実は
炭酸ガスとアロマが出てきます
その炭酸ガスとアロマを豆に封じ込めるために
行きついた包装方法が
この瓶に入れることだったんです
やはり理解されるのには目立つことも必要です
ただ 残念ながら 大きな誤算は
僕がすっかり高いコーヒーを売る
コーヒー屋だと思われてしまった事なんです
僕が考えていたのは この品質のピラミッドの
全てのコーヒーを美味しくすることです
つまり 美味しいコーヒーがとれる
山の高地だけではなくて
中腹でも 低地でも
人権を守りながら 自然を守りながら
コーヒー作りをしている人たちがいる
その人たちにどうすればもっと美味しくなるか
そして どうすれば
市場性の高いコーヒーが売れるかを指導し
その彼らのコーヒーの市場を作るのが
僕の仕事です
この品質のピラミッドを具現化する
すばらしいチャンスに恵まれました
2011年に
JAL日本航空が客室のコーヒーを
美味しくしてほしいと依頼してきたのです
現在 日本航空の国内線 国際線
ファーストクラス
ビジネスクラス エコノミークラス
それぞれのクラスで それぞれの品質の違った
美味しいコーヒーが提供されています
これまで世界各国で
栽培や農園開発をしてきましたが
今 タイの北部のゴールデン・トライアングル
と呼ばれている
ミャンマーとラオスの国境地帯
ここに住む少数民族の人たちと
一緒に働いています
彼ら以前 生きるためにアヘンの原料となる
芥子（けし）を栽培していました
ここに手を差し伸べたのが
タイ王室のメーファールアン財団です
芥子の栽培を止めさせ 森林を復活させる
プロジェクトを創りました
芥子の代わりに
コーヒーとマカデミアナッツの
栽培を始めたんです
そして 女性の雇用のために
陶芸 織物 紙漉きの工場を建て
職業訓練を始めました
徐々に村が豊かになり 森が蘇ったのです
そして さらにコーヒーに力を入れたいという
財団からの依頼で
僕は４年前から
ここのコーヒーアドバイザーとなりました
そして 現在でも年に４回
この地域に入り 少数民族と一緒に
コーヒー作りに励んでいます
これまで世界中で
コーヒーの農園を作り
技術指導をしてきましたけど
技術を教える事よりも一番難しいのは
現地の人たちのマインドを変えることです
そのためには 僕は自ら行って
こうすれば こんな良い苗が出来る
こんな風にすれば こんな良い畑ができて
沢山の収量がある
そして 完熟豆を摘めば
美味しいコーヒーが出来る
これを実際にやって見せて
体験してもらうしかないんです
絶対忘れていけないのは
「美味しくなければ 売れない」
ってことなんです
ですから
可哀想な人が作ったんだから
買ってあげようなんていうコーヒーには
絶対にしてはいけないんです
そんな物 絶対 リピートが無いんです
今 タイのコーヒーは
全国のMUJI CAFÉと無印良品で
採用されています
そして 東京大学では
非常にサステイナブルな活動だということで
校内で販売されるようになりました
生産国の人々には
自然と人権を守りながら
美味にしいコーヒー作りに励んでもらい
消費国の皆さんには
美味しいコーヒーにはそれなりの理由がある
ということを理解していただき
品質に対する正当な対価を
払っていただくような市場を作る
それには
「GINZA SIX（ギンザ シックス）」で
オープンした 最高級のコーヒー店から
コンビニの100円のコーヒーに至るまで
美味しいコーヒーのピラミッドを作り
生産者から消費者までが
本当に笑顔になるような
サステイナブルな市場をこれからも
作って行こうと思っています
先日 「GINZA SIX」の店で
とても嬉しい事がありました
20代の若い女性が
仕事で成果を出した自分へのご褒美にと
最高級のコーヒーを
時間をかけて ゆっくりと飲んでいかれました
これこそが
僕が目指す新しいコーヒーの世界です
（拍手）